[Musica]
ero in treno
e di fronte almeno seduto un ragazzo che
stava disegnando il viso di una donna
all'improvviso arriva il controllore per
chiederci biglietti
io gli do il biglietto
e fido che il ragazzo di fronte a me non
si accorge di niente e continua a
disegnare il controllore alza la voce di
ricky del biglietto e lui di nuovo non
si accorge di niente
vedendo che non aveva sentito edito con
la spalla e lui fa un movimento strano e
tutto imbarazzato dice scusate è solo
che quando disegnano mi accorgo di
niente
il mondo esterno e non esiste ci sono
soltanto io e la mia tavoletta
ho visto questa scena e mi sono chiesto
da dove vengono le persone così si
percepiva un sentimento veramente forte
che volevo sapere perchè a me non era
mai capitata una cosa del genere volevo
sapere perchè tantissimi amici
continuavano a dirmi di sentirsi vuoti
come io mi sono sentito per diverso
tempo
anche io volevo essere come quel ragazzo
anch'io volevo innamorarmi di qualcosa
così mi sono chiesto da dove vengono le
persone così è la mia conclusione
iniziale è stata che è solo questione di
fortuna se non sei fortunato non puoi
trovare quello che ami perché la
passione qualcosa di puramente emotivo
non la puoi trovare razionalmente
ma è completamente
sbagliato quello che ho imparato è che
si analizzi bene il tuo passato se ti
guardi bene dentro succede qualcosa di
straordinario
ognuno di noi è in grado di trovare la
propria passione ognuno di noi è in
grado di trovare quello che ha ma
ho creato una community che riunisce
centinaia di giovani talenti under 30
che lavorano in diversi settori ragazzi
pieni di energia che non dormono di
notte per fare quello che amano e ho
chiesto loro come hai fatto a trovare la
tua passione
sono rimasto sorpreso nel vedere che non
tutti l'hanno trovata in modo naturale
circa un anno fa ho fatto una scoperta
che ha completamente cambiato il mio
modo di pensare ho scoperto cinque punti
essenziali che hanno permesso a
tantissime persone ritrovare quello che
amano quello che ho fatto è stato
codificarli e trasformarli in un
semplice esercizio che ho sperimentato
in primis un me stesso poi sulla mia
famiglia e su tanti amici con risultati
efficaci
se unirai questi cinque punti anche tu
potrai trovare quello che a me se ancora
non l'hai trovato
ora uniamo l'insieme
partiamo da quando eravamo piccoli lo
psicoterapeuta eric meisel afferma che
con grande probabilità quello che
amavamo fare di più da piccoli e anche
quello che amiamo fare da grandi un mio
amico da piccolo a mola vendere per
pochi soldi alcune magliette suoi
compagni di classe vendere lo faceva
stare bene non è un caso che ancora oggi
a distanza di anni lui ami vendere e che
abbia creato un propri commerce quando
ero piccolo io amavo ascoltare le storie
che mio padre mi raccontava anche perché
le reinterpretava le facevo mie e
cambiamo tutto la trama i personaggi il
finale a volte ne inventavo per
raccontare la mia sorella
primo punto della tua storia
qual è la cosa che amavi fare di più da
piccolo il secondo punto fondamentale
cioè qualcosa che sia un libro letto un
film visto qualcosa che hai fatto che
hai ripetuto in modo ossessivo in un
brevissimo lasso di tempo sappiamo che
quando ci troviamo di fronte a quello
che ci piace il nostro cervello
rilasciato pamina che il
neurotrasmettitore associato agli stati
o fori c se trovi uno stimolo attraente
il tuo cervello
siccome prova piacere nel liberare
dopamina ti farà tornare sullo stesso
contenuto in un brevissimo lasso di
tempo per provare la stessa identica
sensazione come afferrò il
neuroscienziato mark lewis quando ti
trovi davanti a quella che potrebbe
essere la tua passione di 20
ossessionato ti faccio un esempio a una
mia amica che non aveva ancora trovato
la propria passione è capitato di
guardarsi un centinaio di episodi di
fila di grey's anatomy in poco più di
due settimane
non è un caso che qualche settimana fa
sia stata messa la facoltà di medicina
a me è successo con i libri in un mese
ho divorato cinque libri di john grisham
sugli avvocati e in realtà le uniche
parti che mi interessavano erano quelli
in cui gli avvocati parlavano in
tribunale per convincere i giurati li
consideravo degli idoli
anche io volevo comunicare come loro
e ancora non lo sapevo ma amava così
tanto quei personaggi perché in loro
vedevo qualcosa di me
a questo si lega infatti un altro punto
importantissimo quello dei beatles cioè
dei personaggi che abitiamo di più che
possono essere i personaggi di una serie
tv di un film di un libro oppure
ovviamente dalle persone reali libri
dicono qualcosa di chi siamo per quello
che in psicoanalisi si chiama meccanismo
di identificazione
proiettiva questo significa che la
caratteristica che ami di più del tuo
idolo molto spesso è già dentro di te fa
parte di quello che sei ma forse non te
ne accorgi perché inconsciamente si
sottovaluti
analizza bene la personalità del tuo
idolo
terzo punto da unire
ora entrano gioco le esperienze quarto
punto da unire
ogni cosa che facciamo ci rende la
persona che siamo durante questo
processo è fondamentale chiedersi come
mi ha trasformato questa esperienza
anche le esperienze che consideri meno
significative o quel fatto per poco
tempo dicono qualcosa di te io per
esempio per qualche anno fatto karate
teatro e ho studiato il violino
chiaramente tutte queste cose mi hanno
reso la persona che sono anche se non
erano la mia vera passione
il karate mi ha insegnato
l'introspezione il teatro ne ha
insegnato ad emozionarmi ad emozionare
la musica mi ha insegnato ad ascoltare
analizza bene le esperienze che il fatto
che sia uno sport gli scout un attività
di animatore uno strumento musicale
un particolare laboratorio che è
frequentato
l'ultimo punto da unire riguarda invece
il tuo migliore amico la tua migliore
amica questo perché diverse ricerche
dimostrano che i nostri più cari amici
ci conoscono meglio di quanto noi
possiamo fare con noi stessi tagli o
falle questa domanda cosa c'è di
speciale in che secondo te mi rende
diverso da tutti gli altri
quando le ho chiesto al mio migliore
amico subito mi ha detto o sei simpatico
mi fido di te
allora ho insistito e ad un certo punto
mi ha detto
non lo so so solo che quando sono con te
mi sento ispirato perché questo è quello
che spesso succede è che molto
probabilmente succederà anche a te
quando glielo chiederà subito magari ti
dirà cose scontate ma se insisti e scavi
a fondo ad un certo punto smetterà di
parlare di te e inizia a parlare di se
stesso di come si sente quando è con te
qui dentro ci sarà qualcosa di
estremamente utile
ora prendi quello che amavi fare di più
da piccolo la tua più grande ossessione
per un film un libro qualsiasi cosa la
personalità del tuo idro le esperienze
che hai fatto e quello che il tuo
migliore amico la tua migliore amica di
civita se io prendo i miei puntini
riunisco
si capisce chiaramente che quello che
amo fare
e comunicare
ora anche tu
unisci i tuoi puntini e trova la tua
passione e se pensi di non avere gli
strumenti
se pensi di sentirti vuoto o di non
essere all'altezza
non smettere di cercarla
ricordati che nessuno nel mondo alla tua
stessa combinazione di esperienza
interessi passioni
sei unico e se qui per fare la
differenza con quello che ami sai qui
per fare la differenza con quello che
ami anche se la tua passione non dovesse
diventare il tuo lavoro anche se gli
altri dovessero criticarla o di
rivederla
unisci i tuoi puntini trova la tua
passione
e fai la differenza nel mondo
con quello che ami
[Applauso]
[Musica]